let's look first at the little things we  noticed that are similar about the two  ronnie has her right eye closed while  melano has her left eye closed ronnie  also has her twin at her side which  maybe it's just me thinking this but  looks an awful lot like melano with the  opposite side open like melano as well  when melana disappears after talking to  her she leaves a blue sparkle trail that  looks a lot like the same trail ronnie  leaves a lot of people speculate about  the tattoos i don't think they look too  similar but they both have tattoos so  that's gotta be something they're also  the only two npcs in the game that seem  to have a connection to torrent melano  obviously giving you the ring to call  upon torrent and ronnie giving us the  spirit calling bell that she says used  to belong to torrance former master now  let's get a bit deeper with this